I've always been a big believer of
professional excellence and that's what
I try to achieve and then when I came in
into golf I done differently because no
one had ever trained
no one ever lifted weights when you have
to make a putt you make a putt you have
to hit this shot he hit the shot my
minds want me a lot of tournaments but
physically I always felt that I wasn't
as good as I could be he's an American
professional golfer who's among the most
successful golfers of all time he's been
one of the highest-paid athletes in the
world for several years he's been the
world number one golfer for the most
consecutive weeks and the most total
weeks of any golfer in history
he's Tiger Woods and here's my take on
his top 10 rules for success number two
is my personal favorite and I'm curious
to find out which one you guys like the
best and also as you watch the clips if
there's something that Tiger says it
really resonates with you make sure to
add it to the comments with quotes so we
can see what really resonated with you
that there is such a thing as perfection
in because we are human we're all
technically imperfect so how can we ever
achieve perfection but what I can I will
tell you this that I've always been a
big believer of professional excellence
and that's what I try to achieve I know
I can never get to a point where I hit
perfect shots every time and I just want
to become the best I can be and that
that to me is professional excellence
I don't know what he's gonna do here but
this is
I'm gonna watch this
can you feel me
but doesn't athlete like you Tiger Woods
Michael Jordan Diego Maradona what do
you have that at the end of the day you
become bigger than the sport itself how
they were necessary bigger than the
sport I think that we've had so much
success in the sport and I think it's in
the way we've done it whether it's
through just pure dominance or maybe
someone may have a more flashy
personality as well as dominating some
people or let me do it differently than
anyone's ever seen it done before in the
past and I think that's where I think
people kind of gravitate towards what
what Messi and Ronaldo are doing now in
soccer is just phenomenal but two
different ways to different ways of
doing it right and then you have Jordan
coming into the league he did it
completely different than anybody else
and then when I came in into golf I've
done differently because no one had ever
trained
no one ever lifted weights no one ever
ran ran miles over ever do just wind
sprints no one ever did those things in
golf so I did it differently and I had
the success doing it differently
and I think that's what people sometimes
see and have gravitated towards this
week was the pro jq-- of 20 year old
Tiger Woods
I guess hello world huh
202 yard par 3 with a 6-iron
ix all in one of his young life yeah
that's yours
Tiger do you ever get tired of hearing
this do you ever get tired of people
watching you asking your questions
you're 18 years old there's gonna be a
lot of people expecting a lot of big
things out of you
well that's fine they can expect all
they want but I've always had this one
bonus to my to my personality my
expectations are so high no matter what
anybody else expects it's gonna be
lesser than what I expected myself yeah
so that's that's a big bonus and plus I
we don't give a darn what they think the
Northwood lighting is good for slime at
the bottom of the downside and he find
them magic the chipper daddies
thousands of seconds is quite incredible
the most difficult shot
to perfection
you should learn something from each and
every single round you playing every
single round should learn something or
there's one thing it might be 20 things
learn something for each and every one
and I've done that everyone that I've
played I've come back home I've
critiqued my round I've looked at it
from the middle and mechanical side what
went wrong what went right and apply it
to the next day Tiger now with a 6-iron
one good straight shot middle of the
green two putts should make him the
champion
well I think my dad always taught me is
that if you pull out effort into it
you're gonna get results but you don't
put any effort into it you're not
getting results out of but more probably
you don't deserve any results so I'm
gonna get out which put into it and one
of the things that my dad always always
did when I was growing up it was kept a
competitive and fun and I'd love to
compete so he kind of just always fed up
on that and my whole goal my entire
childhood try and beat my dad look at
this light look at this shot he's got to
go dead vertical and get a ridge he's
got to carry this just barely over the
long dress I took such a big cut at it
to try and take the water out of play
don't have to go vertical with the super
high lob and this take his chances did I
go in
is it
at 14 he was already a scratch player
and at-15 Junior World Championship
titles and he knew exactly what it was
that sent him apart from his rivals my
competitiveness that's hard as a sort of
brings me through in the clutch when you
have to make a putt you make a putt you
have to hit this shot you hit the shot
you just sort of like drop into another
zone and you block out everything that's
really helped me well we're back at the
17th underwater scene it is Johnny
I have seen a number of players putt
from the back part of the screen results
have not been good
honey that's
better than most
most
most
something that I have always treated
golf as I've treated golf as a sport and
because I've played other sports growing
up as a kid and competing against people
who did train in that sport we all
trained physically to become better able
to compete it would be asinine for
someone to go ahead and not trained to
play American football or for someone
not to train to play basketball so
that's why I do all the lifting is why
not do all the running I do all the
training that it takes to become
physically prepared to play
Tiger 167 yards
this one appears to be online
again
which felt that I've I've always been
pretty tough mentally always felt that
I've always had a mental edge over a lot
of my opponents than me and I have the
physical ability to back it up but I
always felt that I I could play with
them mentally I had to desire to win I
wanted to beat you but sometimes my
physical abilities weren't weren't there
and that's why I need to get my physical
abilities up where I thought my mind was
I wind my minds want me a lot of
tournaments but physically I always felt
that I wasn't as good as I could be and
I think that's what I've been working on
to where I'm at now Tigers got 152 yards
should be just a nice comfortable
non-iron form they're going to go nuts
when he hits this thing
I think there are probably two goals
that are are pushing me right now one is
get the whole time win record only three
back of Sam on that one and obviously
the major record um you know for back of
of Jack but I got to put in perspective
you know I've done it for this by 19th
year and I've had 79 wins that's a
pretty good clip and the key is be able
to maintain that over the years I want
to be able to do this for I would regret
finishing number two and then either one
of those lists if I didn't put the
effort that I thought I could have and I
felt that I've done that so far in my
entire career I'm going to continue
doing difficulty here the Tigers I put
too much backspin on it
Marcus if I knock it down I like that
play and I like that shot
suddenly vaulted
the time for second
so right now I like to meet Tiger Woods
and his father Elwood
that other ball
girl how old is it how old are you tired
- 2 - 13 huh bill - 13 I want you to
check this one out of six iron oh
goodness
let's not take a deep breath well this
is some guts right here oh then the
pocket money went right this is right on
line
get any better than this guys
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because mr. t3 asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you are made of profile next leave the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of the top
10 rules had the biggest impact to you
and why what change you're going to make
in your business or life now after
watching this video leave it below and I
will join in the discussion if you guys
see quotes and other people have left in
the quotation marks make sure to give a
thumbs up to the ones you like the best
and finally I want to give a quick shout
at the Thomas model Vani Thomas thank
you so much for buying two copies of my
book really means a lot to me for those
of you who are interested in getting the
potential shadow in a future video make
sure to grab a copy of the book and then
email in the receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you soon
I've never seen a guy you know be able
to flip the switch from loose and
laid-back to wanting to absolutely kill
somebody like he does you know and not
only does he just want to win but he
wants to just bury you it's a story I
tell many people it's a part for their
Wentworth and I hit it about maybe two
feet a foot and a half behind the hole
and heat it on the back edge and he
putted it down and damn near made his
putt for birdie and so I threw him his
ball back and I just expected him to
give me my putt he turned his back to me
and started facing the 12th tee so I
looked around and I was about five
thousand or three thousand people in the
gallery and I didn't know what to do and
so I started to mark my ball and I put
my ball down I turn around I said tiger
and he says Peter I says what I said
give me this a little whinging
make sure I remember that next week
and he looked at me he says would you
ever want a hole yet have you and I'm
like whoa
alrighty fine
so I finally won my first hole I walked
back to when I said let me tell you
something pal I said if you ever make me
put a putt like that again our
friendship is over
it's hard to explain I guess it's just
sport because it's that's what we do
that's what we we have to do in order to
win I'm not their tournament to to have
fun and talk to my buddies and enjoy
being around them I'm there with the
tournament now half the term is over
with hey let's go party let's go have a
great time